le retour de l' affaire grégory à la une
de l'actualité huit ans après la
découverte du corps de l'enfant dans la
vologne selon notre confrère le point le
procureur général de dijon dans son
réquisitoire définitif conclu à
l'innocence de christine villemin
le mystère reste entier à lépanges
commentaires de dominique dumas
l'annoncé d'un probable non lieu de
christine villemin inculpé en 85 pour le
meurtre de son fils gregory a bien sûr
suscité la satisfaction de son avocat
alors la justice
elle doit encore faire un petit effort
elle à redresser l'erreur jolivière elle
à redresser ce calvaire qu'a subies la
mer cette incarcération du 5 juillet
1985 qui heureusement n'a duré que 11
jours
autre affaire l'inculpation pour le
meurtre de grégory de bernard laroche en
novembre 84 bernard laroche fut tué par
jean marie villemin le père de grégory
en mars 85
l'avocat de la veuve marie-ange laroche
ne voit qu'un aspect positif dans ce non
lieu
jean marie villemin hassan d'un à la
roche va enfin être jugé voilà donc
cette personne qui a tué le 29 mars 85
ghana laroche qui en ce moment était en
liberté et qui n'étaient pas jugées va
être jugé on va mettre fin à cette
absence de jugement d'un assassin enfin
pour la partie civile l'avocat des
parents de jean marie villemin
l' affaire n'est toujours pas élucidée
pris huit ans qu'ils cherchent la vérité
ça fait huit ans qu'il souffre et on
vient leur dire qu'on ne pourra jamais
trouver l'assassin du petit grégory cei
ne l'accepterai la chambre d'accusation
de dijon devra donc statuer sur le non
lieu de christine villemin en dernier
ressort le 21 septembre prochain dans
cette affaire qui aura été l'une des
plus médiatisées des années 80